you found yourself at the junction where
worlds meet politics civility how about
honesty in this country folks
entertainment and a whole bunch of other
stuff without having a healthy body
image you've a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body it's not a
big home of food market in Detroit we
are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio strangest
animal
you're getting louder with Crowder
[Music]
spiritus
[Music]
glad to be with you that's the sound of
the weekend hi i'm your host steven
crowder louder with credit comm for
references podcasts and other tomfoolery
producing with me and video studio as
always is Jared who is not gay you can
follow him on Twitter at not gay Jared I
fulfilled my legal obligations draw your
own conclusions we're good very good
we're good we wish we were coming to you
under better circumstances here
this evening but we still have a pretty
pretty impressive show lined up for you
all things considered we have Tommy
Sotomayor I know I'm not saying that
properly of course noted I guess you'd
call them sort of black cultural
commentator perfect time with the riots
going on and all of this peaceful
protesting yeah okay that's right off
the bat does this if you have any
question as to the level of quality you
should expect from this program Chael
Sonnen formerly UFC fighter big trump
supporter actually noted conservative
you see him on Fox News as well he's
going to Bellator so there's some sports
news and some political news some
insight I think he has on Hillary
Clinton's health and then we have a
Courtney as always who will be in
Courtney a cure job talking about dating
talking about news of the week and
literally Hitler literally literally
Hitler is going to be on the Fuhrer on
later we're going to have him live there
was a big video about Hitler and Hillary
Clinton this week that went semi viral
so we're going to be talking with him a
lot has happened this week it's so
here's one thing we get we get some
insight accidentally doing a once a week
program so stop asking us to go daily
hashtag never daily it's not going to
happen but we didn't talk about the
Chelsea bombing no last will because the
show broadcast Thursday night and it
happened Saturday saturday up and by
this point in the week nobody remembers
it it's not even on people's radar some
would argue that's by design and why
well because there's been an absolute
outbreak of violence across the country
of course black lives matter what we'll
talk about Chelsea will talk about the
celebrity stuff going on but we've got
we've got it get into this listen we're
going to run a clip later on a montage
here so if you have children
in the show I know sometimes you do it's
not age-appropriate because we have to
show you what's going on in Charlotte of
course we had was it Terrence crutch
ursin crusher Crutcher sorry crusher and
then Keith Scott is the the Charlotte
situation people didn't wait for the
evidence as this broadcast is going up
looks like the officer in the Crutcher
situation has been charged with
manslaughter I watched that I commented
on Twitter saying this looks odd but it
it looks pretty damning if the video is
correct then where evidence came out and
of course opinions change and Keith
Scott we don't know anything other than
black officer involved as far as we know
black police chief came out and said
that this man had a gun several reports
have said that he did have a gun and
officers asked him to drop it repeatedly
so that is the setup and now disgusting
life-altering riots taking place in
Charlotte I you know I do think about
Martin Luther King and you watch and I'm
not just saying a couple of isolated
incidences we're talking about cars
being tipped over we're talking about
kicking homeless people because they're
white kicking them in the spine all of
this you'll see we're talking about
dragging white people there's a video
right now in Charlotte of a gang of
black young men I feel even awful
calling them men if you want to call
them that
beating a white man in a parking garage
stripping him naked and dragging him
across the concrete
listen if if that were to happen with a
group of white people in one black
person it's the kind of thing roots was
created for but they couldn't show you
that scene on television for the
adaptation if a bunch of white guys beat
stripped and dragged a black man across
the concrete if that happened to once
this is happening I'm at sin Charlotte
right now if it happened once from white
people to a black person and it would be
reprehensible of course I wouldn't
excuse it it would be front-page news
everywhere to the point where they would
be asking Donald Trump about it to the
next press job I don't like that even
needed to have a video for that to go
viral someone just say it so just say it
someone just say it and it is it is it
is disgusting if it happens to anyone of
course but the point is this is
happening so much right now in Charlotte
to put into context there are far more
unarmed innocent people who have been
harmed in Charlotte probably since the
beginning of this broadcast then will
occur throughout the entire police force
in the United States this year it's not
even close and here's something that's
also important we can see intent when
you have these videos even this woman
Betty who shot Crutcher manslaughter is
like running someone over with a car she
shot once it's yes it still doesn't mean
she's a racist it still doesn't mean
she's going out there shooting black
people as people want you to believe
simply because she hates melanin in the
skin it doesn't prove that it could be
it proves maybe that women make crappy
cops like Jared was saying they have to
escalate force if we want to talk about
de-escalation well you want to put the
strongest guy in there humanly possible
because he's got control over it you
don't want to put a smaller Weeki weaker
woman for whom we had to lower the PT
requirements okay
it proves anything that women make
crappy cops maybe she's a racist maybe
she's not but there is without a doubt
racism occurring on a scale right now in
Charlotte here's the thing I watched
this video and I have to tell you listen
I people get I'm a Christian I have to
hit my knees in prayer because I have to
guard my heart against hatred when I see
a guy getting stripped beaten with an
inch of his life and dragged across the
concrete by a gang of hooded bandanna to
black men I want to see those people
hurt and I have to tell myself of course
this is not indicative of all black
people okay and as a Christian you have
to believe that all of these men can be
redeemed of course I believe that right
but here's the thing most Millennials
don't Millennials the younger people out
there right now they weren't raised with
family matters fresh prints they weren't
raised like we were in a post-racial
America black lives matter is carrying
the black Olympic torch and they're
watching these videos and they're
watching this unfold in Charlotte and
guess what you're gonna have more racist
than ever because people watch that and
they want to see these thugs get blown
away
I mean beating up a homeless guy I think
you see that to me that's a Kubrick film
you know we don't have the audio in our
version you'll see why but I think we
couldn't but if you if you were I think
that's one of the most Dameon parts you
hear the laughing and the gawking as
they kick a homeless man at the ground
yeah I'm here that the laughing and the
carry on like it's like the like someone
you know did a funny magic trick it's
it's it's like the moderate Muslims
watching the lispy guy gets
off the roof by the extreme Muslims it's
that there are enough people in
Charlotte watching a white 65 year old
homeless man getting kicked in the spine
again the total is what matters I'm
giving you some incidents to try and
draw a personal connection but there's
more footage than you could watch in a
lifetime you could hear this social
justice right now why why if the only
these people get so upset when this guy
was shot and I got shot and you know we
watched my wife and I watched free state
of Jones last night and it just happened
to be a coincidence my parents
recommended it it was in the queue
pretty good film and you watched this
and my wife and you know brings us to
tears a black slave and an iron yoke and
you're washing it and he finally gets
free and all they want is to learn and
read and vote and they're voting
Republican and we're watching it my wife
and I washing gone oh my god think
you're rooting for this man because it's
a good man you don't even care that this
is a black but this is a good man and
you're rooting for them and then you go
back to reality and you see the
perpetuating of every single negative
stereotype from black lives matter and
by the way when you look at the hashtags
these stereotypes they're brought upon
the community themselves and if you try
and reach beyond them Ben Carson's not
black who else herman cain's not black
Conda Lee just say they're not black it
seen was the only barometer right now
for black lives matter not all black
people black lives matter which is
important you need to understand they're
not even a majority but they're given a
platform because of a complicit media
these people their barometer for no
longer being black is success and I'm so
pissed off I'm so pissed off I hate that
you have the concern that not
conservatives there's these new factions
the white nationalists who completely
destroy everything that we've tried to
work up to build because we can have
someone like a Tommy Sotomayor we can
have an Alfonso Rachel there are plenty
of black people out there of course who
speak out and do so much good and so
they're muddying the waters and then I'm
furious with the people who are out
there rioting and killing and destroying
lives and shooting and bashing heads in
the concrete who are bringing shame
shame if you're gonna say I'm black and
proud you're making it about race you're
bringing shame to your race you're
bringing shame to America you're making
us a laughingstock on the national stage
and the internationals
but you are if you're going to make it
about your black you're bringing shame
on your black if you're wearing that
t-shirt and it's such a far cry from
what these people wanted when you watch
these it's such a far cry if you look at
if you look at MLK and you look at the
Republicans and the people who were it
with it worked with the Voting Rights
Act its if for context you know what
let's let's give you this speech in this
montage hopefully this it's a nerve it
is a dream deeply rooted in the American
dream I have a dream but one day this
nation will rise up live out the true
meaning of its Creed we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal
I have a dream that one day on the Red
Hills of Georgia the sons of former
slaves and the sons of former slave
owners will be be able to sit down
together at the table of brotherhood I
have a dream that one day even the state
of Mississippi a state sweltering with
the heat of injustice sweltering with
the heat of oppression will be
transformed into an oasis of freedom and
justice I have a dream my four little
children will one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character I have a dream today
you
and I know what that'll be that clip
will be pulled and guess what just a
couple of white guys in a den we don't
know what we're talking about it's
racist right I'll be right back
hey Jared what are you doing shooting
bad guys with what where'd you get it
pfft not guys I'm on state it more
clearly so our audience can hear ar-15
calm that's better
they sell guns now yeah they do are they
any good
they're the best we're from air 15 accom
Kapoor come on you really make that
sound denied the budget for side of the
bag with wife ar-15 from where air 15
accom hey how do you know they're bad
guys Debra's in burkas kaboom that's
racist
on now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
[Music]
all right there now Timmy I know you're
a teenager but if I've told you once
I've told you a thousand times you can't
park your vehicle faced into oncoming
traffic come on let's move gee officer
I'm sure sorry can I just go back to my
car no I want you to follow my
instructions either get down on the
ground or follow me away from the
vehicle what officer can I just get my
PCP now well you know usually I'd say no
but you can make it quick come on get on
out of here you white rascal oh boy oh
boy
what pickle will they find themselves in
next stay tuned for next week's
installment of adventures of the white
privilege boys
[Music]
glad to be back sorry for depressing
people were reading the Twitter for like
I'm so depressed uh we're sorry about
that by the way I do want to correct it
was black lives matter the kick happened
in London with the homeless guy oh
really okay everything else you saw was
Charlotte so I think the point remains
by the way London not exactly this are
we are we supposed to believe that
officers in London to the systemic
racism of the United States the blood of
the slaves in the fields of the United
States it's somehow run all the way over
to London I dealt with that in Canada we
have kids trying to act like like they
were from from Memphis like Drake is
this is a half Jewish butter-soft [ __ ]
who played the paraplegic who couldn't
outrun the school shooting in Degrassi
and now he's he's rapping first name
great is from myth by the way just to
know how wimpy rap has become you know
that that the lyrics know its last name
ever first name greatest boy like a
sprained ankle ain't nothing to play
with a sprained ankle they used to be
talking about GATS you won't even play
with a sprained ankle this is the street
cred now it sounds like a basketball
problem there it sounds like a
basketball problem yet again more proof
that basketball players Yoda sprained
ankle isn't hockey it's a season game
mm-hmm it's every single season game
Tommy Sotomayor coming up after the
break and then of course literally
Hitler here's something interesting that
happened this week people were asking me
to say that the when I say of course a
chanc and it's true we do notice that
whenever I do an impression of something
it bleeds in frankly truthfully quite
often and now with shank I've been
saying of course because some people who
don't know I will sit there and just
listen for you to chanc non-stop like a
morphine drip and then you check
yourself into the Institute yes exactly
if you check yourself into Heath Ledger
to Arkham Asylum piece duh Barack Obama
went in front of the UN this week god
bless him and when you're the boy who
cried globalism that's the buzzword now
it doesn't mean anything when it's
actually happening let's roll this clip
duh not Donald Trump Barack Obama was
before the UN
and in so many words you'll hear him
here saying basically we're going to
give up the United States we're going to
give up freedoms of the United States in
order to appease the international
community that's globalism here's what
globalism sounds like sometimes I'm
criticized in my own country professing
a belief in international norms and
multilateral institutions but I am
convinced that in the long run giving up
some freedom of action how about none
not giving up our ability to protect
ourselves or pursue our core interests
but you want us to do that to binding
ourselves to international rules over
the long term enhances our security no
it doesn't you ask it does not do that
at all and you here's the know people
always obelus when you say globalists
are taking over your water when you say
globalists are taking listen that that's
a buzz word that's thrown around so much
nowadays and you hear you know this
election is about nationalists versus
globalist well I understand that let's
stop using the buzz words this election
for a lot of people and I would say
correctly is about do you believe in the
United States as a as a wonderful
country that shining city on a hill is
Reagan described it or do you think that
the one-world government that appeasing
the UN is more important it's about
those priorities absolutely but this is
a man right there sitting before what is
effectively a global government an
international governing body who by the
way have known the UN might as well be
called though we hate the United States
and Israel club club mm-hmm that's
really what it is I can see the
anti-semites coming out by the way did
this Hitler video this week was
surprised at some people who like Hitler
and we're furious I'm okay with those
people being mad at me that's a good
crowd I have a yes it's a good crowd I
have hit you this is this is globalism
it's not hidden it occurs right before
your eyes you don't need the conspiracy
because this is actually occurring in
real time let me give you another
example of globalism this is funny too
because you have these all right people
sometimes who go
well we're nationalists you know and
then they they come after us and well
why are you a climate
first off we're not climate deniers if
the earth has warmed about 1.5 degrees
in C eighteen hundred's fine humans
could be contributing to it fine
am i a denier that 192 countries who
sign on to a globalist policy like the
Kyoto Protocol would at all stop the
Earth's atmosphere from rising another
one point five over the next century of
course you're not
of course I denied that if people want
to look to some kind of globalism and
then claim that they're scientists and
accuse people being science deniers read
up on that Kyoto Protocol 192 countries
have sign on it will literally kill
people I'm not misusing literally it
will kill people through of course
skyrocketing energy costs of course
through these people the Codel protocol
they want an international governing
body to be able to tell you what cars
you can drive what kind of energy
factories can use quotas and caps on
what kind of products can be created or
what kind of farming can take place
depending on carbon emissions once you
let them through that back door
you're going to have 192 countries
telling the United States and its
citizens that you can no longer drive
your SUV or buy petroleum products you
don't need to look for a conspiracy for
globalism you just need to see what
they're saying right in front of you and
I was there at these climate summits
what people say where your science and I
am I will never back down from this I
was there at the camping can't conclude
summit when Ted not Ted Kennedy gosh no
he killed the girl does it I was I was
there when Ted Ted Turner I was like Ted
Nugent what's wrong with that second
Asia to Ted Turner Ted Turner CNN asked
the the panel the committee to consider
implementing chil
China's one-child policy to curb climate
change literally not misusing literally
China communist China's one-child policy
in order to curb carbon emissions from
an overpopulation problem that is not
occurring overpopulation is not a
problem it's not the issue that we
thought it was going to be first off
it's sort of self negating secondly we
have plenty of space so this is the the
Obama UN quote I don't know for you I
was sitting there washing it with my
mouth going
and then I had my mouth closed and I
smile that makes sense yeah since my
right
it sounds that seems about like Thursday
that sounds like something he would say
this is the same guy you know it took
these are people who are willing to go
right uh what I haven't what do I have a
UN speech well let me go over there and
give up some rights but it takes them
five days to admit that an Islamic takes
five days to use the word bomb you'd
like to think the grown-ups are in
charge there are no grown-ups
you're just a word just as grown up
maybe okay now you're just as much of a
grown up as Barack Obama only he was
smoking crack with his with his domestic
terrorist in college this is everything
you hated of social justice warriors and
he's your president you're getting what
you deserve
Tommy so tomorrow so tomorrow Sotomayor
stay tuned or you're racist
[Music]
[Music]
skittles taste the imaginary racism on
now for The Adventures of the white
privilige boy
[Music]
now okay Timmy Bobby and Johnny if I've
told you once I've told you a thousand
times I need you to put your guns down
can't I just keep my gun on me trained
on you just a little longer now boys you
know I'm not supposed to let you do that
all right just make sure it's unloaded
nope okay now okay now at least you're
not that tackle right you're blind in my
eyes what am I gonna do with you you
little rapscallion Oh boys
what pickle will they find themselves in
next stay tuned for next week's
installment of adventures of the white
privilege boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was the music of Pogo of course
great friend of the show another man who
I hope he comes a friend of the show
first time guest you can follow him on
Instagram Twitter TJ Sotomayor I know
him from YouTube Sotomayor TV we had
Phil advised on the advice show people
are saying all right if we can have this
guy on you're going to have to have
Tommy Sotomayor on so Tommy thank you
for being with us sir
oh no problem Stephen but thanks for
having me no we're super happy to have
you here now right I had seen your stuff
before and people after Phil advised
we're saying this would be a great
counterpoint and I looked up your stuff
and even though you're not you're not
expressly political you get into a lot
of the cultural issues you know with
regarding the black community you sort
of waded into Colin Kapernick and you
you you did a video that caught my
attention resupply
are safer around the white people than
black am i am i miss quoting that no a
lot of us feel safer and the reason why
because violence isn't something that is
shunned amongst black people as a matter
of fact you see all of this rioting
going on and i hope we're gonna get into
that shirking harlot but you don't see
any of this riding going on when the
blacks are killing the blacks all when
you look at something like chicago right
now when you have over 500 people so far
that she had murdered you'd assume that
they'd be out there riding saying that
black lives matter then but apparently
they don't when blacks are killing and
murdering blacks so how can i feel safe
around the same people who feel like at
the drop of a hat I can kill you are
mainly well it's funny because you say
this at one time you know we had Larry
alderaan and we had Phil advised on it
one time for you to for anyone to say
this would be your an Uncle Tom or of
course me with my white privilege I'm a
racist so why is it though you're pretty
popular do you feel like there's there's
a swinging of the pendulum where a lot
of black people
agreement with you saying yeah we've got
to do something about this a lot of
black people are tired we've been
basically held hostage to the idea of
you'll be called a sellout our Uncle Tom
Morricone they will literally call you
it's like the liberal social justice
warriors if you ever tried to have a
discussion with them and they don't like
your point or if your point is factual
the way to get around it is to call your
name
yeah that's true it is very sure we have
in fact gotten into it with said social
justice warriors so what like this week
a good example we have two situations we
have Terrence Crutcher my pronouncing
that crutch recruiter I always pronounce
it wrong being french-canadian and then
Keith Scott Keith Scott of course which
is now led to the riots as you've talked
about in Carolina what's your take on
those as far as what's happened and is
it an indicative of systemic racism okay
now I don't believe it's I don't leave
it's indicative of systemic racism where
the systemic racism but you do have a
problem with the fact that these police
aren't trained number one and I've
talked about it on my radio show last
night the police aren't trained very
well and number two you have both sides
which fear each other imagine if you're
a black kid and you were raised by your
black mother usually and your black
mother told you beware of those cops
like Coyne Grimes the woman who was shot
in Baltimore how she was telling her son
at the age of five to fight the cops
yeah let's grow up having this distrust
mistrust of the cops imagine if you on
the other side if you're a young white
kid and you grow up and you see the rap
videos and you see the news and they're
telling you that these people are bad
now one grows up to be a cop one grows
up to run the streets they both don't
like each other from the time they were
little so we have to address this from
both sides because both sides are
telling the other side that they're bad
and then you're just running them out in
the street like it's a jump ball in
basketball and seeing who wins but many
cases though we do see like Keith Scott
you know a black police officer a black
police chief or you see like with
Baltimore I think you're right in most
scenarios when my dad was raised in
Detroit right during the Detroit riots
and he would say this and I know people
are going to get mad when I say sir
again say that say that were racist he
was part of when they did the integrate
the cross district busing integration
system and my dad said you know he
remember having a talk with his father
my grandfather who actually ran
reconnaissance in Detroit he was in the
Air Force and he would run
reconnaissance because of all the
snipers in the roof and him and his mom
said listen you're gonna go to school
and you're going to see a lot of kids
different colors can you they look just
like you just go up and say hi and they
beat the crap not have a good experience
like it was it was and that bred more
racism in Detroit and white flight than
ever before and so there was that but I
do think sometimes there are some people
who are taught hey these are good people
be nice to them and then it just takes a
few life experiences where it's not
reciprocated why do you think Steven
I'll ask you from your side why do you
think we don't address that like we will
address a woman who says I don't date
any more guys from this city because she
had a bad experience and nobody will get
mad at her for saying we will address a
woman who says well I don't date any
guys who whatever other people are
allowed to have an experienced life
changing experience but white people no
matter what happens to them I've watched
so many court cases of there was one in
Tennessee in particular a white father
had to sit there and not only know that
his daughter was raped and murdered and
thrown in the trash can but all these
black people were claiming racism with
the cops and the evidence show that he
did it but he couldn't say the same
thing but if a white person killed my
daughter or anybody in my family I can
come out and say those damn white people
right now I can say whatever I want to
about white people all over social media
is true and never have a fear of being
put on Team CMN or Fox News or wherever
but you say it you're immediately done
and it doesn't matter what it is that
precipitated you having them well I got
so much flak packager never laughing
because of corn games I'm sorry this is
like we'll get the ones that occurred
this week corn gains is cut and dry that
was child abuse that woman was a child
of either the way she was treating her
kid I got flack because we ran a clip we
miss it and I said you hear repeatedly
yelling you gonna fight the acid you
gonna fight the answers that's exactly
what she said we're like well you know
you have to do the racist impression
it's I mean if I do an impression of
Bill Cosby and we do no one says that's
racist I do an exact reenactment of what
she said to her son and people were more
about that being racist and the fact
that she was basically advising her son
to get into a fistfight with the police
officers now you know what I'm dealing
with as a black man they have come to my
page when I'll do a video on a woman she
could drown eight kids stabbed five more
and burn two but if I say one who is
this woman I want to avoid her block
when it comes to trick-or-treating I
used to date her in college but that's
another story the point is I will speak
about this and say one word that they
don't like and in the presence of that
word they will forget that the woman had
done all of this vicious stuff yeah and
they say oh you're you're a self-hating
which I don't understand cuz even if I
hated all black women how does that
translate into I hate myself even if I
hated all the short black people how
does that mean I hate myself that's
another thing that liberals do we need
social justice warriors they just knew a
title and the title supposed to scare
you off of telling the truth and that's
what happened with you
the woman's a child abuse a period the
one was a child abuser and the cops were
I mean there are instances like when I
talked about I remember the the Eric
garner case as someone who does you know
growling I'm like well you know what
that cop didn't need to do the crossface
that was a guy on a power trip the guy
who was the therapist with the autistic
person shot in the arm I'm going now I
don't think that was racism I think that
was a very nervous rookie cop who had no
idea what he was doing again even if
they make a mistake and there are many
ances where they do then you have to get
to the question of intent and I think
more times than not the intent is not
let's go lunch a black guy today it's
it's either an accident or there could
be definitely some police officers who
are more scared for example we can talk
about Terrence crusher well PCP in the
car we don't know if there's PCP in a
system but I know police officers many
in Detroit who've dealt with people on
PCP you deal with one guy on PCP you are
going it's going to change the way you
approach perps forever mm-hmm I talked
about the young lady and her name is
that Betty she'll be nice about her and
I said well she entered the scene first
a small woman like that and a big man
like that notice she never switched
weapons which means she started off
having her service weapon trained on him
not
her taste right which that you know she
understood that she's walking into a
situation where she's out man
so she pulled out the final solution
instead of the lead-up to the final
solution because if pepper sprayed
there's Tasers there's other things that
you can do but because she was by
herself she started off that way well
and by the way for people who don't know
if you're on PCP you don't you don't
feel tasers you're almost impervious to
pain specifically PCP again we don't
know it was in a system we know was in
the car but that changes everything in
regards to non-lethal options right but
they didn't know that that was there so
we do have to say that they didn't know
how this was afterwards right when she
came upon him she was by herself so she
went to the Final Solution knowing that
he's so much bigger than me if I try to
tase him he could do a whole bunch of
stuff I think what happened was what you
said which is fear she had fear going
into it and never thought everyone else
has their taser pooled I don't I think
honestly thought that she had what they
had because they all hid their tasers
yeah and where she started off with her
gun yeah and I think that's an example
of a mistake but I even tweeted the only
thing I tweeted out about that and we've
talked about this more today was I saw
the video I said at first glance this
looks pretty damning and hopefully truth
and justice is served I had only seen
the video of the shooting because that's
what was being shown then I saw the
video the 30-second video of you know
many police officers coming out drawing
their weapons and him walking for a good
30 seconds backward to the car I do know
enough about police work that no one
will ever say put your hands where I can
see them and walk back thirty paces away
from me they're gonna say get on the
ground so there was there must have been
and this is what they've said some
commands hey hands up
get on the ground they would not advise
him to go back to his car and then the
argument becomes I don't believe the
cops they're lying but it's pretty easy
to look at protocol with that and say
alright this cops would have told him
stay where you are they would have never
told him to back off and it seems like
an unfortunate situation but again
people run you see that with white
people all the time right these kind of
situations occur all the time is it
indicative that that woman hated him
because it was black and wanted to shoot
him I would say no as of now no I'd
agree and I had some of the family
members calling to my show last night I
don't know how much
truthfulness is in their statements but
they claim that he was told to go back
to the car and I kept saying well that
doesn't make any sense why he would be
told to go back to the car and we go
back where you may have a weapon it's
not for a car but then there's also
people on the other side are saying well
and I don't know if you've heard it but
there was the 9-1-1 call from the lady
who said that he said the car was about
to blow up so they were saying
specifically the cops believe that he
may have had a bomb in then I said let
it make it sense either because they
will never trailed him to the car where
the bomb was no so a lot of the initial
reports are contradicting contradicting
themselves now they're finding out that
he had just gotten off a nine year jail
stent which they weren't making him out
to be a um a pastor and that he had done
nothing but he literally just gotten out
of jail inmate he had three active
warrants on him and I'm like I don't
know what to believe right now but what
I do know is that even the fact that the
woman took one shot we do know and I
talked to a lot of cops who crawled into
my show last night they have the DA she
only shot once I think she realized she
shot a bullet instead of a Taser and
that's why she wants you begin yeah
that's that's a good point to the amount
well it's funny too because people talk
about this whenever you get your
concealed carry course I don't know if
you ever have they say hey listen this
is why you want a bigger caliber because
people in a jury they don't know if it's
a 22 they don't know if it's a 32 they
just see nine rounds in the body so
you're better to get to 45 there are
different schools of thought on that but
again one shot is important some of this
is news to me I'd love to see more
honest I didn't know about the jail
stint yet you don't you certainly don't
see it anywhere and I'm pretty on top of
the news now we go to Keith Scott
there's no video this is what's again
spawned more the riots in the riots in
Charlotte Charlotte yes Charlotte okay
so what they went from [ __ ] bathrooms
that was that was the protest - now this
there's always something going on in
Charlotte what's what's your read on
this one the officer said again black
officer a black police chief saying he
was armed and then what bothers me is
the immediate reaction is cops lie about
everything
yep now again it goes back to what you
were saying
your father sometimes when you had bad
incidences you will jump to that bad
thing just to protect oneself get bit by
one snake you're probably gonna think
they're all venomous
even though it's just the one right I
think a lot of the people are jumping to
these incidences and these thoughts
because maybe they've seen enough lies
well I forgot we have to go to a
commercial break our evil corporate
overlords
hold that thought on that note a snakes
have no problem with but spiders are
soulless killing monsters I am totally
okay generalizing Tommy Sotomayor
everyone stay tuned
[Music]
breaking news I'm Carrie Mathison
Oh mr. Winkle cutters following dolls
from Cheers
collins the CEO from skittles candy is
release a statement hi thank you for
convening here today on behalf of
skittles candy
I would like to repudiate Donald Trump
Jr's comments as offensive insensitive
and repugnant and I would like to inform
you that we at skittles are proud that
none of our candies to the best of our
knowledge have ever taken part in any
form of terrorist activity nor does
anybody at skittles candy condone any
form of discrimination against any
marginalized group well that is true
some people have choked on the candy but
I don't have the resources available to
me but I would assume based on the
actuary tables that's possible
has hurt brown people well I will hear
us as his press conference unemployed
revenue rule Crowder
[Music]
[Music]
there we go he's a gamer you can follow
him on Instagram Twitter TJ Sotomayor or
Sotomayor TV on YouTube I highly
recommend it if only for the comments
section because my god it heats up
quickly glad to have you back sorry
sorry to cut you there you were talking
about Keith Scott and people's own
personal experiences yeah I understand
it's horrible obviously people to
generalize and assume that all all black
people are criminals
on the flip side you know when you see
if you look on Twitter or you look on
social media there is an absolute I
guess sort of people are just apathetic
if you just generalize that all cops are
killers and they're lying and they're
planting evidence people just seem to be
ok with that narrative right now you
know it's I will say something on the
opposite side well I have a few white
followers and I've done videos where I
call black people niggly bears and all
kinds of stuff go ahead laugh yeah I
can't I can laugh I can't say it but
I've never even heard that before that
yeah they were like oh this is awesome
this is hilarious well I called the
woman who shot the guy in Tulsa snow pea
so the same white followers who had been
following all of my stuff me talking bad
about black people for years saw one
title and said I didn't know you were
racist I said whoa wait a minute all
that stuff I've been saying about black
people you are ok with that the word
snow pig bothered you so I think it's on
both sides people are ok with what you
say as long as it's backing them yeah so
a lot the blacks are ok with saying all
cops are bad when the first people they
call when something goes wrong and soon
the cops those same bad cops that you so
come to shoot you but it goes away down
the other side too is the black guy when
I come out with a conservative point of
view
white people are patting me on the back
good job brother but if I say one thing
that then they don't agree with they're
like oh you're just like the rest of
them I was like what yeah there is an
outrage culture on the right - that
really bothers I've gotten that - and
although I've never used the term [ __ ]
you Pig yeah I definitely noticed that
really just they get mad about one issue
you know even if I'm like man I don't
like the Trump wants to you know you
look
the libel laws oh you want Hillary doin
no I don't but it's perfectly within the
bounds of reason to say this is very
upsetting for a Republican candidate
yeah and and that is and then they have
I will tell you this is a true story
what happened at a conservative news
network
I mean news network that leans more
conservative and there was a guy who
came in and I swear to you I don't think
he was racist what he said was was
blatantly racist I don't think he he
didn't mean it in a hateful way he meant
it as a compliment and he went up to my
black friend who had just gotten done
talking sort of about black lives matter
and this guy went up to my swear to you
and he said hey man I just wanted to
shake your hand after Obama it's good to
hear a black man say the truth for once
and I know what he meant to say now my
friend was like oh thank you and he knew
and the guy they talked for 20 minutes
he could have easily gone to the
n-double-a-cp and filed suit sometimes
white people just they say the wrong
thing but they get offended easily too
and it's it's silly it's also silly the
outraged culture yes and that's the
problem right now the first thing that
people jump to they don't wait for
information they don't wait for facts
they jump to the cops were lying and I'm
with you on that I think that's is a
horrible precedent to set for your
children for your neighborhood for your
community because you can't work with a
group of people that you believe are
blatantly lighting on you every time
something happens you don't want to know
the truth because the truth in your mind
is always they're lying this guy was
innocent you don't care about his
background you don't care about the cops
background I think that makes it very
difficult because I made a video a while
ago and people got mad at me and then a
lot of the the police departments around
the country that started to share this
video and then the police officers had
told on him and said they're sharing
this racist guy's video and I said it
gets to a point where if I was a white
cop I would just wait on everything to
die down in the black neighborhood and
just show up and pick up the body yeah I
not go knowing that if I did my job
they're immediately gonna say you did it
wrong well isn't it funny how they don't
wait for any evidence when it comes to
this but it took them what three days
before they were willing to use the word
bomb with the Chelsea attack it really
it really is it is something that is
absolutely a nerve
but yeah it's it's it's funny they get
they pick one thing and then you lose
them which is sad because someone like
you can make a lot of headway and
someone like you can reach a lot of
people who haven't had years to hear
this kind of thing I think that's why a
lot of people they saw the fill advise
debate and said you have to have this
guy on on the other side of the coin you
just mentioned earlier you talked about
sort of you mentioned fathers in a way
that's okay you said you know we'll
usually by their mom or raised by their
mom talking about single mothers in the
black household we talked about that
with Larry elder and then we had Phil
advised on and he was in well it's not
exclusive to the black community I said
we statistically yesterday statistically
it is a problem with the black community
fatherless households go so yours
so you're saying that all black people
have no dads I said no that's not what I
said I said statistically it is an
anomaly in the black community
fatherless households can we speak
honestly about that and I I think I was
I was accused of being a racist or
something but you just touched on that
what do you do about it and what if your
experience has been with that when
talking on that issue
I talk about it all the time I have a
film coming out called the fatherless in
America and what I concentrate on mostly
in my discussion is how the lack of
reasoning is coming into black community
because you have a lack of the person
held accountable
there's no held accountable in the
household a man you ever notice that we
get cut from the football team if we say
something somebody they don't like and
they punch us they tell us you shouldn't
have said anything
so we're accountable for all of our
actions something that we got to stay
accountable for it even if we have if I
have five kids that I can't take care of
and she has five kids that she can't
take care of where both of us get help
from the state she get housing from the
state I get housed in the state it's a
it's a situation to where me are held
accountable so if you have a whole bunch
of women who are not held accountable
raising the children the children
themselves grow up to be unaccountable
for their actions and that's what you're
seeing out in the streets with a lot of
these he's robbing the bank or he was
robbing someone's house they shot him
but he didn't do nothing there was
literally a story about a guy who had
broken into a woman's house she shot him
and the family came out on television is
you not they came out on television and
said he had just started college
June he needed some clothes to look
fresh and I'm looking at all these women
and I want you to pay attention Stephen
every time you see a shooting of a young
black male the crowd that they interview
is literally a whole bunch of women like
where the hell are the mean it's like
it's so funny that I will tell you
that's being heard of white people being
out of touch with black culture but
that's ridiculous when I got in trouble
it never even occurred to me to say I
had to steal I needed to look fresh um
we keep you for one more segment let's
cue even one more segment
Tommy's Sotomayor Sotomayor TV on
YouTube stay tuned or you're racist for
real this time
if you too
[Music]
skittles taste the trigger a
[Music]
all right go ahead to be back that was
my I was my Indian from Seinfeld I
finger dance you very bad man
Tommy Sotomayor thank you for saying so
to my or what's the Sotomayor TV on
YouTube Twitter Instagram
TJ Sotomayor what's the origin of of
Sotomayor where where's that from Panama
Panama it would not have guessed that
but I would have pronounced it
incorrectly with Sotomayor yeah you know
it's even English why'd you guys
pronounce it correctly is Sotomayor my
or now I thought like Japanese Sotomayor
and we're gonna get letters and we're
gonna say races against Japanese people
we're racist against all of the above um
it is I will say like there is let me
ask you this serious question because
we're talking about that the sort of
needed you to look fresh for college
here's the crazy thing that woman was
comfortable enough making that excuse
because she knows enough people in her
life will be like yes yes normal no like
it's not that's the problem to me it's
not that she said it but she's not even
surrounded by one person in her life who
would say huh Steven Milwaukee kill
Waukee as they like to call themselves
pet incident and the brunt and the
sister of the man who was shot got in
front of television CNN also ran to lie
in which she was calling for peace no
she wasn't
she said don't burn out our stuff down
go burn down the white people's stuff
yeah and you wonder why white people
will be afraid of black people when they
just stood there in front of a group of
black people said don't burn our stuff
down go burn theirs down and the people
like yeah she said we need our stuff we
need our weed like what yeah she's a
weaver weed we've the women need we've
been there they need this yeah it is
something that they cannot live without
and she said this to a crowd of people
and nobody said but that's stupid
well that's because of this next next
run for presidency Bernie Sanders weaves
are human rights
believe me you'll see it in his issues
list yeah again there's no one around
them to just say yeah maybe go a
different direction let me ask you this
cuz because you talk about and they
wonder why white people are afraid okay
I was raised in Canada Montreal very
much a post-racial a post-racial America
post-racial Canada we were talking about
this family family matters fresh print
some of the biggest sitcoms when we grew
up wasn't black people was like people
who loved these shows Fresh Prince the
dad was a judge Family Matters dad was a
cop do you think those could be made
today no because you have to remember
the down slope of black people war after
The Cosby Show black people that started
to resent The Cosby Show because they
said that's not real that's not
realistic also the rape that'll leave a
sour taste in one's mouth get over that
but the point is you looked at it you
said these people are really wanting
more real representations of black
people and if you notice real means
criminal element there are black kids
right now who are in college who can't
get their parents to give them enough
money to buy books or to get their
family to pull together money to buy
books but they're guys who's doing four
years in jail and the whole family gets
together every month to make sure he can
have money on his books to get some
cigarettes or whatever it is so the
dynamic in the black community think
about rappers rappers in order to do
music have to lie about having a
criminal past and what other venue in
life or profession do you have to lie
about being a criminal in order to be
except to them in prison oh my gosh I
killed so many people if blood will
never wash out of my fingers hey roomie
you know that prison and rap and and and
I do wonder because no we were talking
about that when we were raised and if
you look back sort of in the in the 80s
and the the early 90s there were plenty
of black characters and sort of
quote-unquote white shows and it wasn't
even really thought of it wasn't even
like this is a token black it was just
one of the friends one of the kids
nowadays that's that's not the case at
all it is entirely divided and I will
say that I do think and I am curious as
to someone like you who seems to be you
know
awaken is a black person as a white
person I do worry that my kids will be
raised in a more racially divided
America than I was it seems like they've
regressed do you feel that way that
there's more racial division now than
say 15 years ago well I think it's being
pushed last night I talked on my show
about the fact that there are more
White's killed by the police every year
then blacks killed by the police every
year but those stories don't make the
liberal news because the agenda that's
being pushed that doesn't fit the
narrative the narrative is if you divide
America then you can put all types of
policies in place to be able to lord
over Americans and we're not
understanding racism is a minut issue
but they make it the major issue if you
think about it they got mad when a
little Lane said racism rarely hits me
if ever I can't remember when I got
pissed off with this black guy with
these dreads and tattoos on his face
saying and really hits me I don't see it
a lot of blacks have no idea the other
blacks industry the stuff that our black
guest said Lil Wayne the white way he
said a little Wayne little Wayne are you
50 cents and a little Wayne listen you
look at these people the majority of
black people do not have this experience
the ones that out there running around
throwing bottles and stuff like that
they'll go to job their job the next day
that a white employer and then white
employer can't fire them even though
they saw him jumping up and down he's
like like bottom's call them into the
other side Jamarcus um like I sucked on
television yesterday work for you they
used to be nice on that windshield like
he can't fire on the diseases and even
with me throwing that voice and I did
that on purpose
notice that blacks are able to black
comedians can make the joke about the
white voice joke about the white walk
joke about all things about white people
in white audience members have to laugh
but if you a white comedian you do that
same joke what happened oh but I find it
hilarious that's one thing I hate when
the right reacts are like why can they
do it it's like well because it's funny
so just do it on the other side and be
funny or like why can they say the
n-word and because they can so just just
just do something where you can be funny
so I don't
the outrage on either side but it is
hypocritical obviously I will say you
know I didn't it didn't even really
cross my mind as much in Canada and I I
don't want to use his name in case he's
listening remember in Canada here's a
funny thing right
the Ebonics that's sort of talking it
there there's a history of you know it
goes from Southern slavery and then into
inner cities where people learn to speak
a certain way well that's not a part of
the history in Canada right there's no
there's no way that someone should like
you know Drake who is sorry a half
Jewish butter-soft [ __ ] from Toronto
should sound like he's from Memphis like
that's fake okay and I had a kid there
were four black guys I think five black
girls in my graduating class and he just
kind of talked like you know Canadian
and then I remember hearing like a
mixtape and I remember his song I'm
gonna say butch it was like you know I
got that swag oh no send him like is
that J from high school and he was doing
it to sound like a black guy from the
United States in the inner city it was
entirely fake so the thing that bothers
me is obviously when you have people
like Shaun King and Rachel Dolezal
competing to be black they're competing
for a culture that at this point might
be entirely fabricated yeah the whole
thing is you look at where and I say
this and this pisses a lot of people off
I talk about how blacks speak in America
and I think it's weird because you can
see an Asian or Mexican coming to the
country first generation speak perfect
English yeah we've been 400 years and
people keep giving us an excuse I think
that's the problem I have with liberals
liberals keep giving blacks an excuse to
fail they don't hold them accountable
for anything and that pisses me off
you're treating them like like puppies
like animals it's not worse it's
definitely gotten worse because even you
know my dad who again was raised in
Detroit and we were raised all the black
kids we knew you know I mean listen
everyone has different twangs to their
voice but it definitely was not again
that divide like lingo now that's
clearly been invented by the rat
community it's definitely worse with
kids now raised on the the Drake's the
Lil Wayne's then then even kids you know
from from the Run DMC days in the 90s or
the semblance of okay here's our
commonality with the English language
yep it used to be where the guy would
speak a certain way in
and then he wouldn't speak like I mean
country singers do it all the time God
Brooks doesn't talk like he sings he's a
completely different guy um you could
listen to the guy who's saying used to
saying it wasn't me shaggy
he has no accent he said he learned that
in the military you understand music but
now these guys like plies is a very
educated guy but whenever he gets in
front of the television or a microphone
he has to pretend he's not he has to be
he speaks away in which he doesn't and
what you're doing is communicating to
the people watching you that this is
Norman unlocks black people it's this is
life if you don't speak like this other
blacks will tell you you're not black
black kids have gotten picked on you're
sounding white acting white and gotten
beaten up for just speaking English
properly yeah I had gonna say the
whitest person ever go ahead listen to
them I think I think it what I'm hearing
more and more on Twitter and socialist
Internet is that it is they do have
purpose because it's it's more of a
rebellion against you know the language
the white people create employment yes
we go that too but I mean it's it's it's
a rebellion against the white supremacy
created the English language why why
should we bow to a black friend one time
use the term the oppression home a
diamond and this meant like a woman's
nether region and I was like I'm pretty
up to I was like I've never heard that
referred to as diamond and I realized
there were just a certain point I was
not gonna be able to keep up with it and
I was okay alright let's just let's just
act like this conversation is going
along really well it's starting to sound
like this black friend is the same black
guy no this is a woman and then I heard
it in a song by someone called risque I
can't even repeat the name it's so
profane but it's absolutely hysterical
it's funny if people don't know this
like I I love hip-hop
I've always been into hip-hop and not
just hip-hop on the radio but you know
and I completely disagree with the
politics of like you know people like a
mortal technique and all the stuff today
they're immensely talented um but it is
something where I'm like man I can't put
that on my brain that often because it
is almost always negative well I think
the great thing about being white and
listening to hip-hop music is this you
look at it like how I would look at
Scarface I don't look them
with Scarface and say let me go out and
get me a couple of keys and go down to
Miami and see if I can sell them you
think you guys listen to rap and then
you go on to your regular life but it's
different for blacks we have to listen
to it and emulate it and repeat it we
have to live like what this guy's saying
and that's why I hate the music now
because the people who are putting the
music out are very irresponsible because
they know so I won't say we have to go
to a break people listening we're gonna
give a few extra here on the web
extended because Tommy is is tearing it
up
so to my RTV on YouTube stay tuned if
you don't turn in your racist I got your
back racist
[Music]
hopper wants you to trust him with your
vote but it doesn't end there he wants
you to entrust the direction of this
country to his running mate as well Dean
Cain hopper tells you that Dean Cain's a
swell guy buddy's not what happen tell
you is Dean Cain was won at for rape
Dean Cain swell guy fit for vice
president I think not hopper Cain 2016
unfit unqualified and unamerican people
we shall make was close
[Music]
which didn't expect
jazz hands with the metal that was Tommy
Sotomayor lots of great feedback yeah he
was uh it was great and black beast he
is I mean look Carla back there is it
pre-tape extended Oh getting mad they
say when we say it's a pre tape
we did have to pre tape that and so
there have been some developments
obviously with the officer who's been
charged over there in Tulsa by the way
charge does not mean convicted so it's
important for people to understand that
because I think there were I think the
the officers were charged in Freddie
gray but they weren't convicted and of
course what do you do when that happens
you break stuff it break stuff
you break obviously you were right ahead
of me there okay so we have over a
thousand votes and only a few minutes I
tossed out to the Twitter thank you pcs
beard and everybody else watching do you
think that black lives matter is making
America more racist seventy nine percent
said yes four percent said no seventeen
percent said you are Hitler Hitler or
literally well they just I didn't have
room in the poll for that so and then
after this segment we're going to have
Chael Sonnen on the one and only chill
Sonnen but we do have a guest right now
before that we'll be happy to have him
on do we got it do we have the guest
here ok mr. Hitler Dunham are you there
mr. Hitler mr. mr. Hitler okay yes we
can thank you for being here sir that's
very polite
right off the bat what's better for you
mister okay
my nephew her uh you write a lot of
people thought you were actually dead I
thought people a lot of people thought
you were dead you're a lot of people
that was I can't the consensus
time come again cover a lot of people
thought you were dead
Hitler Oh dead yes tonight for the first
one okay then where did you go what's
okay only because you asked nicely
Thank You Argentina oh yeah I know that
but what do you think in the present now
you've become a bit of a meme that's the
common misconception you know is it's
lazy I know he's mean everyone who knows
me knows I'm not mean no no I you've
become a meme like an online mean let me
show you here that's nothing a frog yeah
that's doesn't mean that's it you as the
Frog it's a meme now very popular yes
you said it that's me that's me okay
let's keep going on like this is going
really well a lot of people in this
election have been comparing you to
Donald Trump making that comparison I
think Steven he's a Republican you know
I I know that but a lot of celebrities
entertainers they've been making the
comparison aim in case you haven't heard
okay so who would you say you're most
like then in the current field I don't
think that comparison is is fair for
anyone
you know I'm an original as the famous
quote gold Crowder
they can walk like me they can dislike
me talk like me and even they don't give
a damn
or shiz and like me they may just be the
next best thing I can do but but they're
not quite me was that was that mmm no
that's for Monogram no that's that's
where I'm an M okay uh who do you prefer
then in this election let's move on who
do you like yeah of course with the
lesser of two evils you know I'd have to
go at this point hashtag I miss her
socialists of a feather you know that
well to be fair he claims he's a
Democratic Socialist very different
Democratic Socialist the changes
everything
let's say hey come on stir kids he
handicaps no leash errands for everyone
who wants to give the handicaps oh but
you know I have to say bother me lead
respects his bait-and-switch game
ok alright let's go on like this is
continuing swimmingly what are you up to
today
alright being twelve people I get five
minutes extra stage time so come on and
bring your instruments to give people
here a simple joke uh no I don't know
how I feel about how many Yogi's does it
take to screw in a light no no we're not
gonna go that there's no way we're not
doing this nope okay love Hitler
everybody we're we're sorry about that
yeah he's he's great for ratings but
he's not terribly great for the
integrity of this pearl no no no he do
better we can I mean what we should have
him back nationally put him on a tight
leash we know we have a black guy a
white guy a woman that we needed we did
you mean to not see the Nazi to fill out
the show so you know you know I mean
they're protected class as well the
Nazis they're by the way I was drinking
I had an in my in my hashtag never daily
mug that won't be in a merchandise store
coming soon kombucha my white hat it can
be good or it tastes like like if a
monkey could urinate vinegar
yeah it is the worst oh gosh I was going
to talk about the Chelsea bombing we
don't have that much time before we go
so I will say that say people are asking
hopper of course you know he's running
for president with his running mate Dean
Cain listen to the podcast technically
they've been under attacks from big
squirrel he did have surgery this
morning he was high as a kite there will
be video on social but he's doing fine
right now
does he F yeah he's laying there with a
cone of shame because he can't eat the
stitches over there in his leg so I had
knee surgery hopper had knee surgery
we're both a couple of gimp's very white
however I mean he's as white as they
come he's a Nazi dog he is he would have
fit in Argentina
dog of Argentina who knows he could be
it could be he could knows Hitler's dog
I haven't I don't know what I don't know
what's up and what's down anymore I do
know we have a fantastic guest next
Chael Sonnen the great one stay tuned
please
[Music]
on the go it also supports this channel
consistent favorites property here and
allow them to continue with their
message so there's that
[Music]
[Music]
all right glad to have it stop it be
professional not gauge you're glad
knowing are you know not how to and we
were talking off there and then sing
just just just bring just bring the guy
on so story here he used to be at Sun
and CH on Twitter now it's his actual
name at Chael Sonnen former UFC fighter
now going to be fighting at Bellator
I've got that right right yeah you got
you got so who's a chest who's at Sun
and CH so southern CH is what I used to
have that was my original name on
Twitter and just to get the little check
mark to get that you know official
verified they call it was like an act of
Congress but I had to go through there's
one morning I wake up they changed it on
their own to at Chael Sonnen which is
fine I just I was surprised at their on
their own but then they also released
Sun and CH and somebody else grabbed it
and then began heckling me from it is he
at least a good troll is he good at it
it wasn't bad you know because I kind of
popped for like I think I favored it or
retweeted at one time so he realized
like okay you know in the spirit of
hail-fellow-well-met
but I think that he was getting ready to
break bad on me yeah I think it I think
he was getting ready to to go crazy and
then yeah they like you don't want to
follow him so you can direct message you
we've learned that one the hard way the
funniest you know Twitter sometimes
you're like God doesn't bother me and
sometimes it can get under your skin and
then sometimes they're hilarious the
funniest Twitter handle I ever saw so
this was immediately after Osama bin
Laden was killed Osama bin Laden was
killed within five minutes was a Twitter
handle at Osama in hell and there was
one tweet wait what
that was it I never so not bad and we're
sitting there got like 75,000 follows
for one tweet didn't go anywhere from
there and you're going someone has time
to do this they should be comedy writers
but instead now they go they troll
people on Twitter yeah one-hit wonder
that's a new that's the modern-day
equivalent so speaking of trolling so
jail you've been Trump guys since the
beginning how do you feel right now
about your chances well nervous not I
mean it's not locked that you know
so fast in this space I mean it was just
three weeks ago he was down by 10 points
this morning he was down by less than
one point point nine it's gonna come
down to the debate and in my opinion
he's gonna have to lay an egg I don't
think he needs to win the debate I don't
think he should win the debate he's
taken on you know career politician or
somebody that's at least been there and
I mean I think he'd have to get knocked
out and say something her I really I
think he's in a really good spot very
good and close race but I am a little
surprised that it's even close you know
it's a it's really bizarre in every
country gets the leader they deserve
yeah if they put if we put Hillary in
and people start complaining about jobs
and they've got no mind all the lies and
the bit you deserve at all because it's
all been out there so cankles every
country gets what they deserve we'll see
we'll see what this one does yeah I
think I think you're right I do
I will say this it goes back and forth
expect Hillary to get desperate
right there the master of the October
Surprise and I don't think Donald Trump
is very good in the realm of debate I
think Hillary you kind of look at what
are the big flaws the biggest legitimate
flaws Hillary is a career politician
she'll lie and say whatever is necessary
to win Donald Trump's biggest flaws he's
kind of thoughtless some people say
shoot-from-the-hip he doesn't give a lot
of thought sometimes before he speaks
which is refreshing to a degree in
debate let's take those two flaws it's a
strong suit for Hillary and debate to be
premeditated to be slippery to be slimy
and I think when you get outside of a
primary when you're getting to a general
public who haven't made up their mind
yet it I don't know it is anyone's game
but I think he could lay an egg he could
I don't think there's a way to win there
I know that it's a fair point and
there's a lot more going on it's also
very funny yeah a lot more than meets
the eye and I think he should just stay
away from that because it's gonna look
like bully and that's one of the
problems historically that men have had
with debating women is they can look
like bullies they can come out too
strong and make them look weak and
and then endear them to the crowd I
think just an emphasis on calmness say
his piece let the time run out and get
the hell off the stage I think that's
what he needs to do I know that's what
he's being advised to do I'm not
confident elate gonna do
well he's it's kind of like right now
we're seeing a subdued channel for
whatever reason we're seeing a subdued
Trump are you uh are you mirroring your
uh am i trying to lead bikes a much more
subdued now you know usually usually
your your you're going you're bouncing
off the walls that's it's mirroring the
truck so here's what's going on I
haven't if we could talk about this for
a second because I have a couple of
thoughts on this first off the Clintons
are so predispositioned two-line they
just they can't not live they could do
it a deal straight and when they prefer
to kink it they just don't know any
difference right and when you look at
Hillary it's like Hillary timeout a
second here first off if you don't feel
good and you're getting up every day and
slugging it out and pushing it through
anyway that's that's really compelling
this is an okay time to tell your story
and say this is driving me crazy this is
and I'm still putting in 17 hour days
there was a guy and I can't wear what
Stata wants to start with an A was
Alabama Arkansas or Alaska but he died
he died going in to the general so he
was on the ballot he passed away and
they elected him and a lot of that it
wasn't because people didn't know he had
died and they were just so used to
checking the box it was out of respect
it was a sign of respect for the guy
that had passed and so Hillary's got a
shot here to just go look here's what's
going on and I'm toughing it out she
doesn't know any different and she
brought up this this monster lie of
dehydration now that's gonna work on
99.9% of the population oh she was
dehydrated she clap it's never gonna
work on me and people from my field they
have to understand Stephen I come from
the one and only job in the world that
you have to make weight in able to go do
your jobs there was nowhere else in free
society that your boss
can put you on a scale before he lets
you go out and do your job so I know
everything you're an intern at Fox News
hydration yes so when she comes out us
is dehydration to most people they just
accept it but if you look at someone
that grew up with a life of having to be
hydrate and lived in that world and
quite literally wrote a book on it you
go geez I have no idea why you lied but
you did so y'all never I you've never
cut weight in a pantsuit and 74 degrees
I tell ya I mean it was insane
I've cut 20 pounds in 17 hours before
100% water weight and I can tell you how
bad you feel but boy you could look at
me Steve and maybe you'd know my face is
something you can't hide dehydration and
doctors love to throw that term around
well you're dehydrated that is the
biggest bunch of BS it is so incredibly
hard to become dehydrated you have to
start with how how did you become me hot
I trained every day twice a day to the
absolute extremes I've never been
dehydrated in my life unless it was by
design
and even then I never fainted in my
entire 31-year career of watching people
purposefully dehydrate one person's
knees have ever buckled that I've
witnessed so I mean it was such a
whopper but she'll get away with it
people don't say no one knows what it
means it's a really really really
uncommon and rare thing and it has to be
done by design that's that's a really
good point so you go not get urine I
didn't know we were going to get into
into medical examination first I
wouldn't have thought about it okay
speaking of which so chill because even
here but here's my larger point this
isn't just a conservative talking point
to try to some grab some Trump's for
vote no it's about the pulse of lying
yeah well it's it's the lie you're just
going hey why are you lying about this
because the truth really isn't all that
bad if you if you were to come out and
say look I'm not feeling good but I got
a job to do man I get it boy there's
days I don't feel good when that alarm
clock goes off you get up and put your
boots on anyway and I just think people
would get it I have no idea why she
would lie and as far as a health issue
goes it also comes back to does it
matter because there's a tipping point
where I get that it does there
tipping point where it does but if
you're just talking about somebody that
doesn't feel good or dealing with age or
she brought up pneumonia which is also
that's another great one to pull out of
the hat most people can't spell a
pneumonia let alone know what it is um
so it's nothing to hang your hat on but
you could also go Hillary doesn't matter
why why would you not just say I'm not
feeling so great what's wrong with that
you know no I agree with Jill I think
he's right she has AIDS speaking of what
you're coming back to fight so you're
coming back quote quotes that you write
it down let's release that on the
Twitter's but not to Sun NCH that guy
knows what he's doing he'll get yes he
will stand in the pocket and trade with
the best of the trolls Chael you came
back
surprising to me you were fighting in
the UFC now you're in Bellator okay this
is kind of the politician in you right
you said swore up and down you weren't
going to fight again your days were
numbered what's that what's the deal and
why Bellator well so in fighting you
have to go with an organization and in
the boxing world they co promote they
mix and blend and in our sport and and I
think largely because it's still a new
sport I think over time there will be Co
promotes both the way it sits right now
is you can only go with one organization
so I end up in Bellator but the sports
the same the rules are the same the
weight class everything's the same but
yeah I'm under that banner and as far as
coming back man I always wanted to but
it wasn't as simple as for me to go
alright put me in coach I was on a
suspension for performance-enhancing
substances
I felt like my race was ran I had some
other distractions going on that were
positives I have some opportunities and
whatnot and I just thought you know
weather yeah I look I'm suspended anyway
maybe we just call it but I didn't want
to I wanted to be able to compete and I
wanted to want to compete you know that
fire is a real thing and when it burns
out man it's it's tough to restock it
but uh that was just the spot I was in
so you're back everyone's talking about
this a lot of potential fights for you
in Bellator listen you just talked about
it performance-enhancing drugs that's
the big question a lot of people saying
is it going to Bellator because there
isn't stringent testing
I don't think I'm letting the cat out of
the bag you've been straightforward with
that sure you said no there's a clause
in your contract where you have to pay
out half a million dollars and forego
your purse if you test positive yeah so
here the way my contract worked is it
would be one hundred percent of my purse
of $500,000 fine but then it matches
with the company you then have to go
with a missionary's commission no I'll
tell you this
that doesn't mean I'm clean okay that is
it that is it's meant to take place of a
of a clean tech clean test trumps
everything
are you saying there isn't it based
basically so I mean you know do we want
it do we want to go into that more like
we're not gonna get to zero that's not
really but last time we had six and that
was a little I think maybe like two is
all right we're gonna grate up no we're
gonna grate on a bell curve and you have
people like you know John James or tilt
in one direction you know judge this is
a bit easy but the truth is yeah I mean
there's a deterrent in place but we
still get tested will do all that same
stuff it's well that begs the question
to people going okay he was gone however
he's 40 right you're pushing 40
you're on testosterone replacement
therapy you were you were taking these
you were one of the few people had a
legitimate exemption and then obviously
not for the other stuff how do you come
back how do you get better if you needed
it back then what does chill look now so
it's hard man like there was other
people that were doing the testosterone
therapy but and but they would come out
and go well it doesn't help me it
doesn't enhance me I'm just taking my
doctor's orders and I was on the other
side of that where it did help me I felt
great I miss it I thought it was a
really great medicine I was glad that I
you know was able to discover that and
yeah it does hurt you know mainly with
your recovery your recovery time changes
something I could you know go to bed and
just be sore and tired I wake up the
next day it's a distant memory I'm ready
to go it's not like that anymore and any
longer break
it's just it's just a reality of it yeah
but it's not ready to get out of hand I
I don't know I think I think maybe I'm a
hypocrite on that because as much as I
enjoyed it and do think it's good
medicine loss I can hold that thought we
have to go to a break sounds like it
might work for Hillary at Chael Sonnen
we'll be right back stay tuned if you
don't you got a racist racist
[Music]
get us taste the outrage papa Crowder is
not only running for president he's
entrusting the well-being of this
country in their hands that was running
me
Dean Cain but America just how much do
we really know about this man did you
know for example that he was a domestic
abuser I don't know about you but is
America ready for a vice president who
beats broads I think not
Harper Kane 2016 unfit unqualified and
on American people
[Music]
glad to be back wow you're really happy
yes I was really a feedback that was
gelsin and sorry we missed we couldn't
have chillin for another segment because
we had some other stuff going on here
that's that's a little some chaos has
been breaking out in the United States
so we had to move some things around you
have it in case you haven't noticed and
and chills a wonderful guest but people
are getting shot people are getting shot
actually we have Courtney coming up here
soon people love her Courtney Kirchhoff
at Courtney scoffs on the Twitter one of
them I think one of the best writers
around and not just because she writes
for me I've always talked about this she
is just she is as sharp as they come I
wanted to get into a personal story here
my wife might get mad at me but I think
she sees where I'm coming from you and
if you could only see her show map what
this segment is called called don't
don't do it
I was in the grocery store with my wife
and I saw this woman with her boy he was
probably six I would you know anywhere
between five and eight I would say
probably six or seven and he was not
crying he was wailing a little lip thing
and I thought oh maybe this kid is hurt
you know I don't know maybe some sort of
sort of sort of delayed colic has gone
around yes
Zika never know and the mom wasn't doing
anything about it he was just sitting I
mean for a good couple of minutes and it
turned out it was over some M&Ms by the
way skittles controversy with the Trump
jr. of course people are meant to be
using it now yes skittles and it's just
the silliest thing anyways the kids
crying over Eminem's
in the line I know some people who have
little boys who are wimps now are going
to get mad at me a lot of women who
watch because they're gonna say well not
my boy
yes your boy I turned to my wife and I
said can you believe that and she agreed
with me by the way she I'm just saying
she might be mad because sometimes she
thinks that I'm more insensitive than I
need to be I didn't say anything to that
kid the mom didn't do anything about it
the boy was sitting there wailing and I
was talking with snot gage I read about
this I cannot ever imagine at that age
being six and just weeping in a grocery
store out of fear of mine could you
imagine doing that at that age now know
how to fear your friends seeing you or
your dad reprimand you said you did it
once right once there was one time and
that was privileged the last time right
and I was talking with my wife I said
that that boy needs a dad to have a
conversation with him now let me I know
what some of you are going to think so
let me bring this around full circle my
dad would have turned to me and said
stop crying right now it wouldn't have
been a what are your feelings again if
there's something wrong you check on
that oh it's about it mm mm-hmm stop
crying right now or I'll give you
something to cry about my dad and I are
very close friends with a young boy he
needs that stern talking-to with that
because that boy will be a wimp
that kid is learning to cry to get what
he wants well that doesn't really happen
in the real world now here's the thing I
was never afraid to cry my dad was never
in real men don't cry I'm not talking
about that and that's why I think a lot
of young men are confused because he
have a mom here I didn't see a wedding
ring there was no dad around seemed like
she was handling everything on her own
so people think you're either neither
need to be a hipster whiny emo wimp or
need to be macho picking up chicks from
the you know that's not what it has to
be but my dad I remember if maybe once
or twice I was being a little too whiny
and the conversation goes something like
listen there's nothing wrong for a man
to cry men can cry that's okay but you
don't want you know the story of the man
of the boy who cried wolf it's like that
you don't want to cry over M&Ms you
don't want to cry in the grocery aisle
to get some candy you don't want to cry
just to get something that you want
because your tears mean something as a
man
because men need to control their
emotions men are leaders and so if you
cry at the M&Ms well your tears don't
mean anything if you're crying because
mommy gets sick or because you actually
hurt yourself and you need help
your tears need to mean something it's
okay to cry it's not okay to cry all the
time and that's where we fought that is
going to offend some people wildly some
women go to war you sing little boys
should cry ever no they shouldn't
they shouldn't and you don't need to
tell boys they can never cry but there
is this idea now that somehow you have
to have a conversation about everything
well why no it's not sometimes just you
check the kids not dying he hasn't sawed
off his arm stop crying I don't know it
just seems to me that not only should
the parents be doing something but
there's a generation of young men who
don't feel any shame who don't feel any
semblance of needing to be a man I don't
know when you were a boy and I was a boy
you know your parents are saying don't
grow up too fast cuz you wanted to be
firefighters yeah you don't I mean I
just it's very bizarre to astronauts
that saltine astronaut think it's kids I
don't dance anymore I don't know we
never went to the moon hoax because they
had a rod on the flag but is it me you
can tweet me at s Crowder is that out of
line I that's the way my dad handled it
with me and I can remember crying twice
in school and well really only once once
I cried into my locker when I got into
my first fight and only my friend saw it
and once the one time I cried when
everyone saw me in school I was kicked
in the penis so hard I had to go to the
doctor this happened in the fifth grade
and I remember her name Amy Amy Leonard
and she kicked me in the tallywacker so
hard I couldn't urinate you have any
idea how embarrassing that is
to have to show that to your parents at
the like I couldn't go to the bathroom
people usually get the crap kicked out
of them yeah it was just a thing that
girls did they just kicked got you
remember that that phase thing yeah
and I just can district and just my
mama's rough
is so abusive and it's so beyond the
realm of normal to line natural yeah now
but and there were no repercussions
number the teacher going Amy that wasn't
very nice that was the one time I
remember crying I just you know II
didn't get that it didn't get the meat
of it it was like a whip it just hit the
tip enough to just like swell it shut
like they like the the the containment
centers in the Titanic that we're
supposed to seal it in that was that's
why it was unsinkable so that's the one
thing remember [ __ ] that she'll
verse which i think is valid um but I I
really do I am concerned with this
generation of young men because of the
social justice leftists right now who
are pushing this idea telling them that
gender is a figment of their imagination
then you have people who are too scared
to stand up and then you have people who
are confused in trying to force this
false sense of machismo on them and
that's not healthy either you know what
no one C to responsibility that's old
thing that's so that you'd learn from
your dad and no one's teaching it yeah
responsibility all those things also
just don't cry like a [ __ ] we'll be
back after this break
[Music]
under Sec unions you can also subscribe
on iTunes or SoundCloud to take louder
with Crowder on the go it also supports
this channel consistence Kravitz
property here and allow them to continue
with their message so there's that
[Music]
okay thank you all for attending this
bi-weekly meeting here at the Islamic
state we know that you are all very busy
but we appreciate it great so if
everybody has the refreshments let's
begin lots of activity this week love to
pick from so let's get right to it
the Mall attack in st. Paul I'm sorry
that's right st. cloud oh I always make
that mistake so stabbings three eight
people were stabbed so that's that's not
bad so do we want to file this one
officially under claim for the Islamic
state just one and it looks like this
stabber no remember we can always spin
that as suicide jihad okay so then I'm
going to mark this one under claim a
shrub if you could prepare a press
statement claiming that one that'd be
great all right here's one I think we'll
all be very excited about a bomb going
off in Chelsea New York where all the
gays are yes so that's great right in
the heart of the beast pressure cooker
pressure cookers don't overlook them
with the pressure cooker I'm looking oh
it it looks like no casualties
now remember Ahmad has been a longtime
friend to the Islamic state okay okay
here you let's file that one under let's
give that one to the Taliban
[Music]
scared of taste the analogy that
triggers stupid people
[Music]
[Music]
glad to be back we will have Courtney
Kirchhoff coming up after the break they
call it miss Wolf's I'm trying to see
what do we have to wear dress herself as
always Jared who is not gay I fulfilled
my legal obligation my apologies for
everything
yes someone asked me to fire you this
week
I mean Jared has fired all the time
behind the scenes so I know you like the
the seeder of it but we've got it we've
got to be authentic I feel like that's a
big selling point of the show is
anticipated contempt should I leave
everything that you are about well not
right now we need to finish the
broadcast we don't have that much time
to get into this and so I don't know if
we just go straight into the clips a
bunch of this is how you know Hillary
Clinton is in desperation mode all of
the celebrities have come out to support
her right away so today as a good
example between two ferns with Zach
Galifianakis it's a Funny or Die program
which is basically a wing of the
Democratic Party you can see Kristen
Bell and they pushed the wage gap myth
and and Will Ferrell with the the actual
show on George Bush the Donald Trump
horrible horrible film with Johnny Depp
did you ever see that just oh it's awful
you totally I'm glad it was he trying
was he not trying I don't know but it
was just the whole thing was bad he was
in some English show when they were
going yo you're incredible with doing
your mimic do you for the audience to do
the Donald Trump anything well I just
say okay a lot and I said no and that's
actually probably better than Johnny
Depp so if nothing else this has
illuminated the fact that Johnny Depp is
horrible he's terrible I've talked about
this everything and it's all you know
Johnny Depp is like the hot topic of
actors he doesn't want to seem
alternative oh I love him I loved him
back I saw her hands yeah I love how
he's dark no he just every character he
gets he plays creepy gay and it worked
for Jack Sparrow didn't work for Willy
Wonka didn't work for Sweeney Todd
didn't work for what was the other one
Mad Hatter oh my gosh I can't even watch
I know they were going hey Johnny what
do you think honey think you can craft
this character for the the Mad Hatter
thinking yeah that's really in
oh my gosh oh just the worst anyway so
between two ferns from Funny or Die wing
of the Democratic Party a Funny or Die
College Humor all this stuff the good
thing is it's unclear display right now
so and right away this is what's so
funny right away it's trending on
Twitter every single mainstream comedian
actor and journalist had tweeted this
out unless you're an idiot you know
there was a concerted effort behind the
scenes okay listen we're putting up this
between two ferns was that Gila fanaa
cousin Hillary Clinton we need some
firepower people don't like her I get it
she's a [ __ ]
we gotta make her seem but but Trump was
outraged over the fact that tousled
thumbs hair so here's a clip from it
just so you can see what they were all
about what why would you play a
commercial for my opponent in the middle
of our interview the Oscar he paid me in
steaks I'd be afraid to eat them if I
were you
it's a good cut of meat I think it's
part of the [ __ ] well this has been a
lot of fun misses when we should stay in
touch what's the best way to reach you
email it when really they're trying to
normalize it yes just because Amy
Schumer says who the email thing wasn't
a thing just because you say that
doesn't make it true
well that's what they have a goes there
just that thing just that how highly
they go and by the way I am I don't know
buddy
I know we're not one of those we've got
caught a lot of flack because when
something is funny even if it's from the
left we go you know what that was funny
yeah this wasn't funny as a matter of
fact was more funny as its name was guy
Josh Sweden
Joss Whedon Joss Joss Whedon he did all
the Avengers Buffy yeah all that stuff
yeah so he did us all celebrities get
together you know the montage of telling
you who to vote for I
that's called a circle yeah yes yes a
circle you know what to be fair
Robert Downey and disappointed to see
him in here was was pretty funny pretty
self-aware this was more funny than the
between two ferns yeah actually a couple
put in the clever punchlines in a couple
of clever punchlines but here you go
this is just the meat of it so you can
understand where they were coming from
this all has occurred within within 24
hours
real clip but you only get this many
fame
people together if the issue is one that
truly matters to all of us a disease or
ecological crisis or a racist abusive
coward who could permanently damage the
fabric of our society do the math do we
really want to give nuclear weapons to a
man whose signature move is firing
firing firing things but we can end this
nightmare before it begins we can save
the day a couple of things I met Jesse
Williams in the set of Greek no idea he
was black no should wear a nametag
someone whose main quality is firing
people you know what I don't think
there's anything there I have some
issues with Trump I don't think there's
anything wrong with bringing someone in
who can fire people in the government
hack I think we need some firings you
just sold me on a more here's what I
love about this this is the first time
but this is not only going to backfire
not only is it going to hurt Hillary
Clinton there's no doubt about that if
you look at the likes to dislike ratio
on YouTube they're pretty close and that
doesn't happen in the land of YouTube
heroes and sweater vest non FCC
censorship um
and it's going to backfire on the actors
people are really tired of being told
who to vote for here's this is what I
love about there's a lot of people may
not remember it they had their Rock the
Vote campaign with kami Diaz in PT I
remember and they always said we don't
care we just want you to vote and even
back then people are saying are you
trying to suppress the vote I always
said if you don't know don't vote I
don't want you voting if you don't know
about the issues if you know don't know
anything and you're voting because
Cameron Diaz told you on the Tyra Banks
Show I don't think I don't want you to
selecting our next president
I'm not forbidding you but I don't see
any any virtue in encouraging you so
banana repeat did he said what would
what is a Sarah Palin gonna do about
South Korea believe it at that they were
saying we don't care who you vote for
and we all knew that wasn't true well
now they're saying don't vote for Donald
Trump now it's clear be when they're
desperate and that going lesson okay all
right week we get it they they can't
hide it anymore and here's the thing
even if there may be right and some of
their criticisms of Donald Trump they
said yeah but you said
George Bush was a racist xenophobe
they've used it so much now that even
though they probably think they're more
justified than ever with Donald Trump
they can't people are going well I know
but back when you said you were just
rocking the vote and you weren't trying
to pick a candidate which you clearly
were you said George Bush was a
xenophobe in a racist he said the same
thing about McCain and Romney so no and
people are rejecting it and people are
tired of it and and this is what's
really hurting Hillary Clinton the veil
has been lifted for a lot of people in
this kind of thing only helps Donald
Trump's celebrities thinking we're gonna
get our firepower together and we're
going to make an impact people are tired
of it people are tired of the phonies
and people are doing phony and they're
tired of of just the pandering and the
talking down to people what were you
gonna say I would say that article that
from the New York Times
what kind of some a viral I think this
week that was talking about that was
talking about how people are so this is
what you've seen with the right is that
people are so tired of this this this
this movements come on so fast with your
trevor knows with your Samantha bees
with your any of them daily shell all
these things it's just that the leftist
agenda left in and you're seeing what
you're seeing is people culturally it
was just what it said culturally you're
seeing some victories and little
Hollywood circles yeah for the left but
what people are doing is it's it's
pissing off the right and they're
showing up at the polls and they're
voting that's where you're seeing
victories in States for your right to
work for your Second Amendment rights
mm-hmm I think that's why you've seen a
surgence of trumpet things because
people are just it's not working anymore
that's a good people are ticked off and
you want that is also important to note
there any kind of a Republican victory
any kind of a conservative victory is
worth ten times the amount of a leftist
victory because it's going up against
all of that if right-to-work passes if
you know constitutional carry laws or I
think what forty eight states now most
states have some kind of a concealed
carry law or open carry law and that
didn't happen if you just go back twenty
years those victories to occur they're
occurring in spite of the Hollywood and
and media machine they're occurring in
spite of the full-court press as opposed
to a leftist victory I mean they're just
riding the wave of the Matt Lauer
the Cameron Diaz's of the funnier dies
and the Will Ferrell's and the Amy
Poehler's and Elena Dunham's and the Amy
Schumer's they have all of it so in
something else to the double standard
here and you just touched on that
Samantha bee can go up and say that
Donald Trump is literally hat liar
Trevor Noah
same thing gosh Stephen Colbert Kimmel
right they can do all John Oliver John
Oliver I love that funny that he can't
be and what I love is but I love the
people from the other countries coming
in telling us how American politics
really yeah um the thing about Donald
Trump is he's an orange men I don't care
what you have to say Trevor Noah and he
mostly because he's Arendt ously unfunny
so all of that that's fine you know
Samantha bee can multitask between
uterus jokes and Donald Trump is Hitler
jokes and they get so the outrage over
the fact that Jimmy Fallon had a
relatively benign interview that he
tussled Donald Trump's hair yeah but
these people just said he's Hitler come
on if you're just going to say one is
more extreme heat uh --sold the guy's
hair so not only are they incapable of
laughing at themselves but the double
standard is on full display for people
to see I mean this is what's happening
right now
politically Hillary Clinton might win
but culturally black lives matter has
created a rebound it's it's created an
eye opening for a lot of Americans
culturally the the Hollywood elite and
even the political elite it's never been
more clear as to who they're pushing
that's the beauty of this right now same
thing with the second amendment same
thing with your your your right to work
in your state it's never been more clear
and especially within 24 hours the
concerted effort of we need to get all
hands on deck all these celebrities with
this video we need to do Zach
Galifianakis between two ferns we need
to go after Jimmy Fallon know that
here's their big offense with Jimmy
Fallon that he was nice to Donald Trump
yeah they don't want anyone to be kind
to him and that plays in in Donald
Trump's favor all he needs to say is
well the media and then somebody goes
too far and he condemns all media if
they're not pro Trump he's not
necessarily going after the fact
they have an inherent ideological bias
but when he just says look at how look
at how far they lean to the left
everyone can see it and even people who
don't like him as a candidate go you
know what yeah I get pretty messed up
it's pretty messed up and you know what
I'm I think I think I'm with you on that
lever pull that's what you're seeing
Courtney cute job when they catch on
after the break stay tuned
[Music]
it is unacceptable and we must be
monetary at but all these videos they
monetize advance if you see something it
is your duty to say something the
monetization at once and now late night
channel surfing with social justice
warriors no I
he's so groundbreaking mr. Trump I was
wondering
your hair all right Jimmy usually I say
no but go ahead this has been late night
channel surfing with social justice
warriors
[Music]
glad to be back with you I don't know
what that dance was my dance I don't
know what that dance I don't know we
need a name for it we should do we
should get a name for it when you get
out of the shower because that's when
you finally get the best moves did you
certainly have more options you surely
have more options options options are
good my personal favorite is the Eiffel
Tower but we can't do it on air we have
our next guest and you know it when you
hear this because when she comes on to
the program you don't have that you
don't have her there we go there we go
she chose this she chose it shows no
dad's which is bizarre crap at Kourtney
scoffs one of the best writers on the
interwebs Courtney Kerr Jeff thanks for
being here sweetheart huh thanks for
having me out of the frame a little bit
out of the frame a little bit and don't
keep clacking that microphone you're
fired what's it what's the little what's
the little mutt dangly ones there on the
necklace what does that mean anything
are just nice-looking oh no I just got a
cost well market look at her she's
putting in yeah we can see you find your
a little bit off frame Jared can kind of
tell you look at that look at that it's
funny that you you you often talk about
gender kind of issues and there's been
so much going on this week and I think
we he bummed people out enough with the
first segment and then we brought them
back we talked about this we just got a
lot a huge reaction from the women on
Twitter with that conversation we had
about men and you've written about that
a lot that you know obviously a lot it
was quite or calm and you've gotten
reactions from from both sides on that
well it seems like I don't know maybe
it's both sides but most of my Twitter
audiences men like 83% and it seemed
like even normal yeah what are you
laughing about not gauging I'm just so
distracted by the half person in the
background yeah I know what it is but
it's just it's scary okay sorry
let's forgive him Courtney it's not a
professional program by the way you're a
very privileged that's when women are
incredibly privileged on Twitter why is
that you and I could tweet the exact
same
thing and percentage-wise you will get
far more retweets because men want to
sleep with you oh cool absolutely I will
tell you this
I've thought Jared and I talked about
these powers I don't know not that I had
them when I was single that was that
when I was single if I got followed on
Twitter like okay any father any father
oh pretty display picture yeah and then
you find out I was like Russian brides
calm Oh skunked again Russian brides
calm but there is privileged you're
going to be careful with some of those
really attractive avatars they're not
real
no they're just men who which is bizarre
because they don't even get I don't know
I don't well I don't know I don't know
that I want to explore I had a
correspondence with a man named Lyle and
I don't feel good about myself over it
but go ahead you have a lot of male
followers Eiffel Tower
no that was I mean you know he wasn't 15
that's nice the mug Anthony Weiner for
crying out loud subtle that is where you
tell me that's a pervert a guy he has a
did a 15 year old girl
that's a weird dude did you read some of
the things he was saying no can we even
talk about it on here probably not it
was disturbing this is like a 51 year
old guy talking to a 15 year old girl
and she was going along with it that's
it's it was child abuse at this point
what can a press release be from him
other than oops yeah unless they just
unless the camera just pans do many
furiously math I mean that's what people
would expect which we know in the name
and it's constant Weiner there's nothing
else with Anthony there's no other place
that can go and you brought him up I
didn't bring up Anthony Weiner you did
you said you had no the kinds of things
he was saying when you said you know the
kinds of things he was saying and it's
only natural for me I mean you lift that
fire and you walked away laughing okay
so try to write this [ __ ]
Oh should we just end the program no do
not end the program no we need Courtney
to write this so you have a lot of male
followers you were talking about this go
ahead okay and a lot of men and women I
think don't seem to understand why we
like the things that we like in the
opposite sex so I was having to explain
like woman's Blaine no there's a reason
women like men who are taller than them
mm-hmm there's a reason women like men
who are muscular and have deep voices
and a few comments reg well isn't that
just what Hollywood has sold us and I
couldn't believe it it's like no one's
heard of evolutionary by biology so and
few people were saying you were you were
a gold digger because you said I want a
man who's successful and you're not a
materialist I didn't say that I said I
want a guy who can take a girl out
that's true
that's what a gold digger that's a guy
with a job no a 2 for 20 at Chili's just
seems like a minimum asking you know
door price it's like the to drink wine
yeah it's it's there are a lot of guys
out there who don't feel good about
themselves and so for a woman to say I
actually want a guy who has a job and
who looks nice all of a sudden men get
triggered it's not just feminists who
are getting really upset about men
saying things about women you guys are
doing it too when women say things about
men so either it's okay or it's not okay
yeah it's okay for a man to say I really
like Kate Upton I like Margot Robbie
then it should be okay for a girl to say
I really find Jimmy Garoppolo attractive
that means that she is the backup
quarterback for New England are you
laughing you look like you're getting
breathless there for a second you're he
was the supreme me that's pretty nice
fan club there I mean yeah I am does he
stand or kneel for the national anthem I
do not know I really hope that he stands
well or sit or squat
what's that he more than a spur for
Clare down yeah you know it's true a lot
of guys want it both ways they in this
this isn't have talked about where it's
like you know oh I can't stand feminists
I get it but then I'm like yeah but
there shouldn't be any expectations on
me to be a man Sam Hall second you want
to do it with feminism you need you need
to step up to the plate as well and just
be the bare minimum
yeah so the reason men like women like
Kate Upton with the nice boobs and the
pretty hair and the clear skin and the
small waist
she's signaling her health and her
fertility so I'm sorry a lot I know a
lot of guys a lot of people don't want
to have kids but if you have a sex drive
you want to have kids it's how we
perpetuate the species it's really basic
so women like a man who is a good hunter
gatherer because if she's pregnant she
can't go out and hunt and gather so
that's gonna be someone who's strong and
who could protect her and who can go run
down the elk that's a man who's decisive
and knows how to get things done
mm-hmm so in the modern times that's
gonna be someone with a really good job
where's a nice suit he's signaling his
[Music]
[Music]
Papa wants you America to entrust your
country to his running mate Dean Cain
but there's a lot that Harper's not
telling
what's he trying to hide for example why
is Dean King seen here bullying this
poor black man what was that about
is he a racist Apple wants you to vote
for him in all white dog in a racist I
think not
Harper King 2016 unfit unqualified and
unamerican take we shall make was cross
[Music]
and we are back with the widest guest
ever at Bernoulli scoffs someone has to
be white this evening but people will
ride over that a few men commented on
Twitter that you look lovely this
evening and we tossed it to some people
to ask questions for you Oh dick morris
[Laughter]
the Pandora's box that you just opened
and Chewbacca's lover wants to talk
about Deadpool or something nerdy I like
that well dad pulls good okay let's move
on
dad it was pretty good I liked the movie
someone asked this yeah nastiest thing a
guy ever did in a first date one this
guy says I got Alfredo spit in my mouth
once well there's a story there that I
don't think I want to follow up on your
flaw I don't think I've ever had a nasty
first date no why perficio I'm going to
say perfect does she date black guys I
did go out with the black guy one of the
first states that the matchmakers set up
with me was with the black guy he was
his parents were actually from an
African country was he prone to looting
he paid so you know I think he paid with
his own money and not he didn't knock
over us good for the program listen now
in the program do you monetize I will
tell you this I I've dated several black
women and one of whom I'm still friends
with she the reason it didn't work where
she was very sexually aggressive okay
and I don't know if that was if that's
typical of black women um III know
Tommy's social such a racist no no she
was very and I had it with two girls one
in high school and one after high school
and that was something that I definitely
noticed I was not used to I was
definitely not used to it was like it
was the flip side and and I also think
she wanted to get married and have
babies and literally six months after
when she was like a little
ditalion okay so there you go people are
asking me to date black guys the answer
is yes she does not discriminate
how about Hollywood changing things
around oh okay here's one your I would
imagine you're a fan of Tom Selleck
I would imagine he's a guy yeah you
don't want to know do you know that
redoing magnum p.i with a woman oh god I
don't know if I do a mustache with that
if it's a non-binary magnum p.i here's
the thing - this is a genuine question
this has gotta stop because it's all
they're doing is validating the idea
that what men have done is better so all
they're doing is copying they're not
coming up with anything original on
their own they're saying well the men
did it therefore we have to do it and
their imitation is the finest form of
flattery they're just giving credence to
this whole idea that masculinity is
better by copying what the men have done
that goes for ghostbusters the new
oceans 8 or whatever it is you guys come
up with to make a 13 or 14 here I'm
tired of it it's it's fine if girls want
to have their own movie but make it your
own movie don't copy what the boys have
done well it's it goes against
everything that it's that they're saying
that therefore it's it's not real
feminism ok remove that from it the idea
that they're they're just sort of doing
these you know Redux of a male film this
could be a blind spot and and this is
honest the way I talk with my wife about
it I want to know what you think do you
feel when you go to the movies and most
action stars are men or most leads are
men when you're watching it do you do
you think yourself like of course it's
another man does it bother you or or
jujin I'm not no no you don't feel like
you want to see more women period no in
fact I go where I go for CrossFit my
instructor he loves comic-book heroes
and he's got decals of comic book heroes
everywhere and one time he said I've got
to get more female superheroes in here
and I said no female superheroes are
lame and there was a girl she's probably
in high school who agreed with me she's
like yeah they're really lame the reason
we like to watch male superheroes is
because men like to be heroes
women don't so much am i saying that all
women don't want to be heroes no there
there's an exception to every rule
but most women don't want to go out and
save a lot of women actually want to be
saved by a strong you've earned because
we're all gold diggers they're gold
diggin Hula's it's a real it's a it's a
problem that's interesting because
you're I thought you quit CrossFit no so
anyways but the thing is right you're
going there and Max is 253 pounds wow
that's pretty impressive but you are
obviously stronger yes you are obviously
stronger than most women and so you're
strong woman going and gonna I don't
want to see female superheroes I don't
so much care about female superheroes I
do get peeved when it's you know
superpowers you can make everything okay
it's just one you know one page of
writing but when you see like the female
like salt with Angelina Jolie or
Charlie's Angels and here's a deal it's
not like Cameron Diaz in high heels
panning a guy which by the way finished
in physics there's no leverage to
sidekick Pentagon stabbed all that to me
is insulting to my intelligence I would
prefer if they just showed us their
breasts so it's called the suspension of
disbelief and in fiction in all fiction
even if it's a fantasy you have what's
called the suspension of disbelief where
there are rules in that universe there
are a lot of people who think oh that
girl she's such a badass she could kick
that guy's butt most really strong women
cannot kick most guys but it just can't
happen so with Charlie's Angels and some
of these other movies your suspension of
disbelief is you can't do it cuz you
know all she can't kick that guy's butt
right so they have to do like they did
with with the Black Widow character
Scarlett Johansson or they've got her
doing all of these weird moves so she's
throwing people off balance and it's
it's a spectacle but the only other way
that you can you could make a woman an
equal and strength to a man is for a
patriarchy to have given her the
strength of a man and that would be
Buffy the Vampire Slayer and I think
Wonder Woman
so which looks like a good movie coming
out hot that's how they sell it to men
that still have this have to have to
sell to men and that's because
it's Wonder Woman isn't really for one
look at her outfit she's there's no way
a woman like that at that outfit is
gonna go into bow are you kidding me
yeah it's not a conversation yeah yes
it's like ah you will take my finest
sword and to you I give my armor under
you
maybe the outfit is to distract the
opposing army true that's a good ones
running out of the trenches and they're
like do I save her I don't know and if
it's a gay superhero in the Marvel
Universe they would just criticize your
outfit so he's away in abstract away
shop with her away yeah a woman in
battle will put her hair in a ponytail
she wouldn't have it flying all over the
place
oh that's a good point if you ever
watched the female fighters there either
they're usually in cornrows yeah which
is a horror and no makeup they don't
have makeup on you there because if it
drips and gets in your eyes er it's not
gonna work they're only two excuse well
there's only one excuse for a cornrows
no and a woman that's and that's that's
fighting it if going on a crappy cruise
can coming back with those stupid little
beads in your hair is is unacceptable
someone wants to know hey Mike chuan
what do you think of Canadians sorry
that's kind of turned into an
online-dating said this wasn't what we
meant to do but that's okay what do I
think of Canadians in what context I
don't know I guess he's trying to say
would you narrow them out no what's your
litmus test for crazy question Stevie
Crowder there are so many people asking
these these these questions I love it
well I mean listen I'm just saying and
of course dick Moore is asking about
your feet well you know it's it's
interesting that you say this and you
get this controversy you know it is it's
one of those issues where you'll have
people who love you and then one issue
and they disagree with you and they
abandon ship completely and sometimes
you get these guys who are hyper ly
sensitive who think they're concerned no
yeah and if you're hyper sensitive and
you get triggered because I said I
didn't want to go out with the fat guy
sorry if you're overweight and you want
to go out with somebody who's fit you
should be fit these are basics and if a
guy is gonna get that easily
triggered it's not gonna work out do not
send me a tweet do not send me a
Facebook message saying that I'm wrong
and I'm a horrible person
you gotta look in the mirror sometimes
if you're that upset about something a
total stranger has said not even about
you personally there's a hefty raise in
it for you if you can get an exclusive
with Anthony Weiner I don't think it
would be hard listen you know it's all
about intent you don't have to make any
of it okay I think I'm probably too old
good point that guy looks like um he
looks I mean because I mean well Anthony
Weiner will provide the race that was
the trick Weiner looks like I saw a
scene one time with that guy I always
forget his name it's not the guy from
Miracle on 34th
I'd either Dimmick Dylan McDermott or
Dermot Mulroney I get them confused the
guy from the practice good-looking guy
yeah there was a scene in a film er he
was like kidnapped by the mob and they
put a ziplock bag over his face to
suffocate him right so as he's inhaling
the ziplock bag it's like sucks in his
face
I feel like that's what Anthony Weiner
looks like sucked in mother's for ya
new information for me to process but
you're right you know like his cheeks
are sunken like he looks like he's been
cutting weight for a wrestling meet or
he has uh-huh like the worst variety of
aids and I would like to hear from any
women out there do you it's just those
photos work for you ladies cuz I'm not a
woman who really likes to see those
creepy if it's like their husband or
something that's like a playful kind of
picture or something like you like
seeing good-looking men if you're
married but I don't think that 15
year-olds know selfie that even a
good-looking man can pull off guys
nobody looks good in a selfie and guys
tend to all look like child molesting
creepers I do a pretty good reenactment
of the Coppertone ad with hopper yanking
at the yanking at my junkies it's pretty
good
it's a pretty good one yourself if
you're intending to look silly I've seen
and they're really funny cuz it's like
you know you can't look good in a selfie
so you goof it up no well that's a big
thing with you know with men obviously
being funny is it's it's it's an
evolutionary mechanism because men wanna
sleep with women regardless mhm sure
just sent me a selfie - no no please
make sure this is work safe I don't know
what's going on behind my back with this
this off I'm sorry people you know
honestly we're talk we're going off on
it because I don't want to go back to
the riots i I just I blew my passionate
wad earlier I can't get back into it
it's too much no it's better to talk
about the triggering gender roles well
it is important as well and a lot of
people simply want to I mean it you know
we're talking with that that little boy
if that were your little boy crying over
an Almond Joy am I out of line and
saying um you want to love it but tell
him like hey cut it out so here's the
thing a few years ago there were some
businesses who put up signs that said
children not welcome um and I had a
friend she's got young children and she
said oh that is so anti life like
there's so much culture of death in our
society now that people hate children I
said no that's not it because we've
always had children and only now our
business is putting up signs saying
don't bring your kids in one of my door
says children please try oh gosh parents
these days aren't disciplining their
kids so they're letting their kids run
crazy everywhere they have this
entitlement mentality especially a lot
of young moms they they think that
they're martyrs to a cause or something
and that their kids deserve everything
and they're raising a bunch of little
brats and people hate it so I I would
have never thrown a tantrum in a store
at five or six I would have been
terrified and it's not the kids fault
either that's it's like a poorly behaved
dog
it's we can't be mad at the kids I'm I'm
it's these parents yeah sorry millennial
parents I don't know yeah it is a we it
is a weird time I I know every
generation has wondered this but I do
wonder what's going to happen when this
group of kids who
been raised in this kind of environment
and they go off and there they're
building our planes you know they're
engineering our roads we have to let you
go at Courtney scoffs read her at ladder
with credit calm thank you very much for
being with us
I'll talk mall talk with her tomorrow
stay tuned we'll wrap this up
[Music]
in the English language
[Music]
glad to be back it's funny with our and
I really appreciate the people who
listen to the people the audience who
listens to the program but it's when I
feel like we're going off on a tangent
or something people go with us and they
appreciate it because we really do
obviously try and cover what what
matters that week and sometimes it's
sometimes it's too much it really
sometimes it's just this week we were
talking about this earlier I was going
man I don't know I don't know how we do
the show I don't so there are some weeks
that are so harrowing and like I said we
didn't get into the Chelsea bombing so
much because so much had happened since
there which is even more horrifying if
you could believe it than the Chelsea
bombing which is crazy to think about
obviously you have Islamic terrorists
who want to blow us about what could be
worse you can understand not that it's
at all acceptable or forgivable why
people raised Muslim would want to kill
Americans in these Muslim countries I
mean Islamic countries places like Syria
you can understand because I've been
indoctrinated with their whole life
they've never had anything good their
entire lives and they've been told that
everything good that comes from the West
is decadent and therefore immoral and
that's something that you get a lot of
unfortunately even Christians they feel
like they feel guilty for enjoying life
which is horrible that's not the way it
should be but so they channel all their
hatred here you can somewhat understand
it but it's more upsetting to have
millennial privileged Americans yep even
black millennial privileged Americans
who've grown up in decent schools who
who have had every opportunity afforded
to them even if they're lower middle
class and certainly more opportunities
afforded to them than then lower class
white people in the United States and
when their parents generation or their
parents generation and they decide to go
out and commit these heinous crimes
against fellow Americans that really is
it's not a foreign threat it's it's
internal and it's and it's an
unjustifiable one when you look at the
evidence and I know you're probably just
showing yep you know what I guess it is
I've kind of accepted that oh you're a
white guy yep I'm a white guy and so I
guess I have a white guy
pinyons and so sometimes you really do
you go into something that first you
know rant that wasn't planned you get
passionate and it's it's hard it can get
very difficult because we we really do
mean what we say and I will say this
I've found myself doing this and I think
it's a poor maybe there's some other
people out there you really do need to
guard your your heart and be careful to
not let it make you bitter like I said I
can only imagine the kids who are being
raised here watching what's happening in
Charlotte or London the black lives
matter and just these brutal attacks and
I can really unfortunately see kids
being more racist and in this kind of a
situation
putting hatred in their heart and from
their mind it's understandable and on
the black side as well because they're
being lied to being told that cops are
picking them off with open season and so
they grew up with hatred in their heart
because of the George Soros is because
of the Hillary Clinton's because of the
Bernie Sanders who want to pander for
their votes and they tell them we must
stop with the innocent deaths of young
black people so they grew up with hatred
in the heart and they Harbor it
specifically toward white people and
then white people see these kids whether
it's on campus saying [ __ ] I love yo
white tears like we covered before that
makes them Harbor hatred when they see
people getting beaten up and stripped
naked and dragged through concrete as we
see in these protests that makes them
hateful and it's easy for it to take
root and you do it needs to be a daily
gut check I've talked about this my dad
there's very very few people I respect
more than my father he grew up in
Detroit you know there were the Detroit
riots um he'll be the first to tell you
a lot of people he knew and a lot of
people who are still there were racist
and for him and for me being a Christian
absolutely in my personal life I will
tell you is a in a system of
accountability that forces me every
morning to look at myself and say okay
what's wrong there and sometimes I catch
it sometimes you do you catch just just
a little Ember of something that you go
what is this why am I feeling this way
and especially in weeks like this it's
easy for that thing to grow and it's
easy for it to grow on all sides it
doesn't mean at all sides are right
doesn't mean that the kid who thinks
falsely that black that that black
people are being picked off by
because all cops are racist doesn't make
that any less of a lie but it it has a
net outcome that's significant and
especially when you see right now in the
age of social media we've talked about
this to the beauty of social media the
beauty of what happens online right now
there are no more gatekeepers we can
have this this audience you guys bigger
than CNN most shows and we're incredibly
grateful on the flip side there is you
know through all the algorithms and
through what people do on social media
people tend to only congregate with
people who agree with them and so
there's an incentive to provide you with
exactly what you want to hear and so
that grows that fans the flame of hatred
or ignorance whatever it is I know I'm
not I'm not talking social justice
warrior language hatred ignorance I'm
talking about actual gut checks for
people out there because it can happen
like Courtney was saying there's some
there are some guys out there who
genuinely have been wronged by women and
they hate women that's not the
patriarchy that's not most men at all
but there are some guys out there there
are some people out there who see what's
happening in Charlotte and they lump all
black people under that umbrella or or
they apply falsely that it's a genetic
factor as opposed to right now a very
very horrible period in time where black
Americans have regressed unbelievably
and it's easy to let that take root in
you in and get angry and it sells it
sells so much we talk about how often do
you hear on conservative AM radio or
it's just the outrage machine and I
always want it to be real when that
occurs on this program when I tell you
me I'm exhausted because this really
does at a certain point it does it hurts
it hurts my heart literally to see those
things you watch it and when we get
horrified just like you do that's why I
don't want to come on this program every
single indigo I can't believe this
country is going out with this country's
crap
well these AM radio hosts and these
conservative Talking Heads I've said
this country is crap forever right
because of the person who's pretty
listen it doesn't matter who's in office
it's still the greatest country in the
world and there's a lot to be thankful
for and maybe that's your counterbalance
but it is really easy to let that
negativity and and yes hate it is a real
thing grow in you especially in weeks
like this
but that also absolves you have
accountability because here's the thing
it's always reversible and so when you
just say this is the way it is and you
allow the anger to consume you guess
what you're no longer able to be
productive so it's not just to feel good
Care Bears it actually can help you
being positive and and becoming a better
person
talk to you next week
[Music]
thank you for watching go to
anti-authoritarian content in this video
it has been d monetized let this be a
lesson to you all it's not
[Music]